Transmann sein in Edinburgh sie die
Battles liebt die queereszenen der
Künstler und Sänger tritt heute hier auf
sein Weg war lang und hat weh getan
seinem Körper viel mehr aber seiner
Seele
[Musik]
vor 28 Jahren geboren im falschen Körper
als Mädchen immer anders als die anderen
gemobbt und verzweifelt
ein qualvolles Trans da sein bis zur
Therapie und der Operation vor vier
Monaten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Narben statt Brüste das war seine
Rettung sagt er es Friedhof das bedeutet
Freiheit ich war so unglücklich so
gequält lerne mich wieder zu lieben
falls ich es jemals getan habe die Haut
in der ich stecke
genau das wollen Schotten und schotten
Trans Menschen leichter machen sie alle
sind in Aufruhr protestieren für das
liberale gendergesetz danach soll jeder
sein Geschlecht selbst bestimmen können
ganz ohne zwei medizinische Diagnosen
die bisher erforderlich sind in ganz
Großbritannien bereits 16-Jährige hätten
freie gender-wahl wenn sie erklären seit
drei Monaten in diesem Geschlecht zu
leben
dann könnte ich mein Geschlecht in
meiner Geburtsurkunde legal ändern
lassen und auch in meiner Sterbeurkunde
und sollte ich irgendwann heiraten dann
wäre ich ein Ehemann keine Ehefrau
ein emotionales politisches Reizthema
erst recht seit das Parlament in London
den Schotten ihr bereits beschlossenes
gendergesetz verboten hat ein Veto gegen
das schottische Regionalparlament ist
zwar möglich gab es aber noch nie
dieses Gesetz hätte einen schädlichen
Einfluss auf gleichstellungsrecht im
ganzen Königreich und deshalb hat die
Regierung hier mit Bedauern richtig
entschieden
klein gemacht von oben so fühlen sich
viele Schotten wieder einmal sie drängen
schon lange in die Unabhängigkeit mit
wenig Aussicht sechs lange Jahre haben
sie im schottischen Parlament um das nun
gestoppte gendergesetz gerungen die
regierende schottische Nationalpartei
Kämpfe gegenüber macht aus London
wir müssen an die Hebel der Macht wir
haben immer noch keine Kontrolle über
Energiefragen Beschäftigung soziale
Sicherheit
und das sieht so aus dass selbst
Angelegenheiten die wir entscheiden
dürfen gekippt werden wenn es der
Regierung weiter südlich nicht passt das
befeuert unsere Forderung nach
Unabhängigkeit
der alte politische Streit eskaliert
ausgerechnet bei einer der heikelsten
gesellschaftlichen Fragen Tabus und
Halbwissen bestimmen eine aufgeladene
Debatte
das alles belastet ihre Patienten noch
mehr die Psychologin sieht die ohnehin
für unsicherten jetzt noch mehr leiden
am öffentlichen Streit über ihre Rechte
wie hast du das sie haben schon so viel
damit zu tun überhaupt in dieser Welt zu
existieren und wenn man ihnen
Erleichterungen Aussicht stellt und sie
dann wieder kassiert dass demoralisiert
viele meiner Patienten haben zuletzt
gesagt dass sie sich in diesem Land
nicht sicher fühlen oder hier frei leben
könnten wir müssen sie unterstützen sie
müssen über so viele Hürden
Richie harens Erfahrungen liefern gegen
Argumente es noch einfacher zu machen
ins andere Geschlecht zu wechseln mit 26
hat er wegen psychischer Probleme den
ersten Termin in einer genderklinik die
erste Frage so erinnerte es ob er eine
Geschlechtsumwandlung wolle er fühlt
sich hinein gedrängt in die
Hormontherapie
die Affe Menschen nicht so beeinflusst
zu werden das begegnet einem nicht nur
in der Therapie das gibt es in Schulen
bei Social Media überall das infiziert
gerade gefährdete Kinder die durch eine
schwierige Pubertät müssen und wenn
ihnen dann einer sagt du kannst das
einfach stoppen viele würden ja sagen
denn sie wollen zu ihren Freunden passen
besonders sein und nicht normal
dann folgt die Operation der
Geschlechtsteile aus Richard wird Abby
doch die leidet weiter an sich selbst
hält die Umwandlung schließlich für den
eigenen Irrtum verloren zwischen all den
Fragen und dem leichtfertigen ärztlichen
Rat
der Arzt sagte wenn du Richard sein
willst nimm die volle Dosis Testosteron
wenn du Appy sein willst nimmstrogene
ich habe mich gefragt wie soll das gehen
als wenn du bei der Behandlung einfach
aussuchen kannst wie es dir gerade geht
Richie ist heute 35 und lebt wieder als
Mann mit täglichen Schmerzen
gescheitertem Sexualleben er wird wohl
versuchen die genderkliniken zu
verklagen
viel mehr Glück im neuen Leben hat
Transmann sie die Battles der
drecksänger im Familienalltag ist der
Vater seiner Tochter mit sie vor fünf
Jahren hat er sie geboren als er noch
eine biologische Frau war
es war eine schöne Erfahrung meine
Tochter fast zwei Jahre lang zu stillen
ich habe meine Brüste gehasst aber dann
hatten sie einen Zweck und als meine
Tochter begonnen hat mich Mama zu nennen
aber ich mich unwohl gefühlt
Trans Menschen zu unterstützen das
versucht Schottland seit Jahren das
gendergesetz polarisiert und steckt
politisch fest die Regierung wird damit
wohl vor oberste gerichtet ziehen
[Musik]
sondern auch als schottischer Bürger
unsere Stimmen dürfen nicht einfach von
Westminster ausgelöscht werden
Schottland hat einen langen Weg hinter
sich wir müssen unseren Kampf fortsetzen
Unabhängigkeit ist die einzige Antwort
ob das schottische gendergesetz jemals
gelten darf eine Frage von Siegern und
Verlieren des Machtkampf im Vereinigten
Königreich